lobby of Ramsey solutions joy is here hi
joy how are you nice to see you I'm
doing well Dave how about you better
than I deserve
welcome welcome so you're here to do
your debt-free scream yes I'm so excited
I love it well welcome so where are you
from well I'm actually from here in
Nashville and I work just around the
corner so I Drive by your building every
day and it was really good just to keep
me accountable every day I drove by him
like all right Dave says I gotta pay off
that debt I'm working on it okay so
you're actually big radio personalities
the truth yes I work at Way FM a
Christian radio station and you go on
the air you go by Troy joy summers yeah
joy summers okay I didn't want to use
your real name I didn't know how to what
the right proper thing was really mess
it up but yeah okay so you're your own
way which is an awesome station it's a
series of stations actually yeah so and
you put your broadcast from here in
Nashville I do yeah I do the afternoon
show so after this I get to head off and
do my own thing well very cool well
congratulations alright so how much debt
have you paid off joy I paid off $35,000
I love it way to go and how long did
that take it took me three years it was
it was a long long time but it was
wonderful okay and you're single
yes alright very cool so what kind of
debt was this this was student loan debt
I went to a Christian University and I
thought this will be great but it was so
insanely expensive and then I ended up
buying a car and I ended up with all of
this debt just starting a career in a
Christian radio station ministry
situation so it was really hard to start
out that way now radio usually doesn't
pay that well in Christian radio yeah
it's tough that's a tough gig it really
is and I so I really admire what you're
doing congratulations so you decided
what happened three years ago what
started you on this journey I think it
was just seeing everybody around me talk
about how long it takes to pay off
student loans and suddenly I realized I
don't know how I'm ever gonna do this
and so I heard about your class I
actually took it three years ago right
out of college and I thought okay I've
got this backpack full of debt what do I
do about it and so I got a second job
right in the midst of getting out of
college and I started balancing both I
have actually another radio job that I
do as well
Wow I've been doing radio in the morning
and radio every evening just to try to
make this happen and I'm so excited cuz
those are some long long work day
and now I've made it which is great very
cool how's it feel it feels great I'm so
excited that work has paid off there was
so many nights that I didn't I didn't
want to work you know extra hours and so
many holidays that I worked on and I
thought this is simply to pay off that
debt like it's it's what I have to do to
get it done yep so what's your degree in
my degree is actually in broadcasting in
media so you are using it yeah you know
you knew you were gonna go that
direction then Oh congratulations well
on you thank you so much I'm
inordinately successful at a young age
congratulations well done very well done
so all right so we're talking to you and
I being on the radio like we are we're
talking to there's joy out there
listening at three years ago and she
just got out of school and she's
probably a little intimidated there's
$35,000 it's like waking waking up with
a financial hangover and you're going oh
no what have I done
and what's your advice to her what are
the keys that allowed you to get this
$35,000 paid off in three years I think
I would tell her to hate her debt with
everything that she has because that
just seems so acceptable I grew up in a
family that my dad's a pastor so I grew
up in ministry and there's not a lot of
money in that and acquiring debt never
seemed like that bad of a thing but
learning how bad it is for my life and
learning that it's possible to get out
of it so I just had to learn to hate it
enough to do whatever it takes to get
rid of it and that meant those long
hours that meant saying sorry guys I
can't come hang out and have fun tonight
I got to go do my second job learning to
make the sacrifices necessary to get
here and to do it as long as it takes
because there were moments I wanted to
give up in the middle year-and-a-half in
I'm like this has been a long time I'm
ready to only have one job but I would
tell her just to keep going well way to
go congratulate fun that is excellent
what was the hardest part for you the
long job the long hours in the job or
what else I think so sacrificing and
just spending all that extra time doing
what I had to do for that extra income I
mean there were times Thanksgiving
dinner we'd have dinner and then I'd say
okay family I got to go in the back and
record a radio show and I didn't get to
spend as much time with them Christmas I
was recording shows for my other job you
just have to do what it takes to get it
done and that does mean you make
sacrifices in other areas but I'm so
exhilarated right
now that I've paid off that debt and now
I can get some of that time back with
family and I can make sure that I'm
spending the time that I need with those
people that I love because I made the
sacrifices I needed to in the time when
I did and now I can be done with that
and I'm sipping full wow you're on fire
this is awesome very very cool so was
that must say your three years I suppose
it'd make you 26 27 yeah seven okay way
to go joy absolutely very very well done
I'm proud of you that's awesome and it's
a great great story all right well we're
honored that we were able to participate
a little bit with a fellow radio
personality here eleven current you were
able to see you turn this around and I'm
glad we were a tiny part of that you're
you're the hero I'm proud of you well
thank you for everything that you do to
inspire all of us all of us girls I just
I just finished another round of your
class and a bunch of single ladies
together we'd say dave says no if we
want to buy something that we should so
you've been an inspiration thank you so
much that's fun well thank you all right
joy from Nashville $35,000 paid off in
three years
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
well done well done well done
oh just like that I like it
congratulations